its moist I got that on camera I'm
uncomfortable now they were trying
Krispy Kremes rivas peanut butter cups
donut my two favorite thing peanut
butter cubs and donuts had a lot of time
and this is a her this is a limited time
offer
yeah we're getting a limited time offer
offer I think anything goes well with
peanut butter I've had a burger with
peanut butter yeah in Vegas it's good
I don't like donuts but I do like it we
see nut butter cup I do not want to wait
it okay that's weird
my high yeah I got to the needle a metal
needle exactly like what it's supposed
to taste like like a doughnut the normal
doughnut yeah what the peanut butter
feel like filling and then chocolate on
top got a little nuts on top and then in
the center is like a peanut butter gooey
cream this creamy incisively does taste
like a Reese's Peanut Butter Cup
so like warm juicy like what we're gonna
do the rest of these donuts eat it I was
gonna say share it should we hand these
out to our great friends and office
[Music]